asking people why they're joining it
sounds really simple and obvious but
people are solving different problems
when they're buying the same thing and
so having a personalized experience for
how they're going to consume the product
and the service at the onset giving kind
of like a unique road map is one of
those things that will dramatically
enhance the value that they're receiving
from the program because usually most
people deliver way more stuff than
someone can consume and so it's like
okay how can I give you the shortest
path to getting the value that you want
the way you want to receive it and so
there's like ways that you can stack the
value that makes it just so irresistible
and such a no for people to stay that
they're like well I'd feel stupid to say
no